[Music]
a year ago we lost the iconic voice of
rocker Tom Petty the 66 year old died of
cardiac arrest in his memory a new
tribute collection called an American
treasure features previously unheard
recordings and live performances in her
first TV interviews since her father's
death Adria petty spoke with CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Anthony Mason
about putting this album together
good morning Anthony good morning Adria
Petty says she wanted to give something
back to her father's fans who she knew
were grieving just as she was the month
she spent combing her father's archives
to assemble the new box set she says
were often painful but also touching
[Music]
keep a little soul is one of the
previously unreleased songs on the new
petty box set Adria Petty a director and
filmmaker produced the video with newly
discovered home movies of her father
wasn't like going through all that
footage it was emotional but it wasn't
sad it was beautiful
since early this year that he says she's
been working on what would become a
sixty song tribute to her dad I was the
one that was like let's call her an
American treasure because he was one
she collaborated on the project with
what she calls a council of elders that
included her stepmother
Dana Petty and Tom Petty's bandmates
Benmont Tench and Mike Campbell founding
members of the Heartbreakers me and Ben
and Mike literally were putting cue
cards with song names on them on the
floor and just trying to figure out what
the story was
they dugout unreleased old gems like
Lonesome Dave
that was one of the months favorite
songs that never was that was what he
calls his white whale
[Music]
and an intimate version of you and me
recorded in the bands Clubhouse
how hard was it for you to listen to all
this again it was absolutely awful for
all of us I mean different different
stages different ones of us kind of
couldn't participate for me you know
there was definitely moments where
people who find me in my pajamas crying
listening to tracks but it's something
that you have to do in service to the
art and the man
[Music]
at any point did you think I've taken on
too much too soon absolutely every day
good day yeah it's so interesting that
you reach for something that big you
know what I mean that quickly I don't
know yeah I guess I just felt like
putting our energy and our grief into
something positive
yeah was a better thing than just
twisting in the wind for you is that
what you felt like you were doing
twisting I felt like it was just such a
shock you know
and I just I hadn't imagined that he
would be dead at 66 and yet at some
point I've accepted that
[Music]
with an American treasure
adrià petit aim to highlight her
father's talents as a songwriter and to
show the human side of the rock stone he
was just so sweet funny and I think so
hopeful he's so filled with hope right
down to the end like tenacity and hope
you know we're just intermingled in him
in such a beautiful way
another rarely seen side of petit
devoted father to his two daughters he
was a good dad I mean he was really
involved with us so we could pick up the
phone and call him like anytime feel
like making a video of Beyonce is
accepting the rough cut there's not
enough close-ups she's really pretty
don't you want to show her Facebook he
was the same with Adria's five year old
daughter
Everly who knows his grandpa and he
never wanted her to go to a show or
anything he was like I don't want her to
think of me like that I just want her to
think of me as grandpa Tommy
one night we left the pacifier up at
their house like 45 minutes away and him
and his wife drove down with the
pacifier that's not an image I would
have had of Tom Petty absolutely what
you left ducky I'm coming
[Music]
Adria petty says the past year has been
cathartic
but that they've just begun to go
through the many tapes in her father's
archives where is all this stuff kept I
can't say that it's in a bunker in a
mountain that's an undisclosed location
the good news is there's more there's so
much more there's so much beautiful
stuff out there one of the things that
that Adria said was so difficult when
going through all this material is Tom
Petty used to make all the decisions and
and and he was gone so they they were
all trying to think you know what what
would he would Tom what would he want
what would he think you know it was such
a huge absence but a daughter's love for
her father is powerful stuff right Sam
is sweet and funny it's just nice to
hear that about yeah yeah what it must
happen like to want to talk to him known
so why did you do this yeah I'm thinking
what a gift she's given us you always do
the best business thank you thank you
Adrian thank you